نداءات الرئيس الاوكراني الاخيره الى
الحلفاء باستعجال مد بلاده بالذخيره
المشكه على النفاذ سرعان ما لاقت استجابه
واسعه على ضفتي الاطلسي ففي بروكسل وافق
وزراء خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي على
خطه بقيمه مليار يورو لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخائر حيث ستتسلم في دفعه اولى نحو
مليون قذيفه بحلول نهايه ايار مايو المقبل
كما اوصى الاجتماع بزياده قدرات انتاج
شركات التسليح الاوروبيه من اجل تجديد
مخزونات دول الاتحاد ومواصله امداد القوات
الاوكرانيه
وتبدو تلك القرارات متسقه مع تقديرات
اوروبيه قائله بان الحربه تدخل مرحله
خطيره وان احتياجات كييف ازدياد لاسيما في
ضوء حشد الروس اكثر من 300 الف مقاتل لشن
هجوم واسع قد يكون وشيكا في نفس اليوم
وبفارق ساعات اعلن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه توني بلينكن تقديم مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 350 مليون
دولار وبحسب بيان بلينكن ستتضمن حزمه
المساعدات الجديده صواريخ هارم ومدافع
هيمارس وهاوتسر وذخائر مختلفه ميدانيا
تحتدم اكثر معركه باخموت في شرق اوكرانيا
ويتبادل المتحاربان القصف والاتهامات مع
تعهد كل منهما بحسم المعركه لصالحه في
النهايه يفكيني مالك شركه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه التي تقود الهجوم على
مدينه بخموت اعلن ان مقاتليه بات يسيطرون
على 70% من المدينه لكنه لم يبدو واثقا من
الحفاظ على تلك المكاسب اذ كرر مخاوفه الس
من ان القوات الاوكرانيه تخطط لهجوم واسع
اوائل ابر للمقبل لقطع التواصل بين قواته
ووحدات الجيش الروسي
وناشد بريكوجين وزير الدفاع الروسي اتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات الضروريه للحيلوله دون
حدوث ذلك لان يتاثر سير العمليه العسكريه
وفق قوله تصريحات قائد ميليشيا فاجنر تبدو
استمرارا لخلافاته المعلنه مع القياده
العسكريه الروسيه في جبهه بخموت التي
اصبحت رمزا للنزاع بين الروس والاوكرانيين
بسبب طول امد المعركه والخسائر الفادحه
التي تكبدها الجانبان